at the peak of covet in march
anxiety-related searches hit a record
high on google
as people were searching for answers on
how to handle a year filled with
confusion
turmoil and grief i sat down with people
who study wellness to find out what that
means and why focusing on your
well-being
is more crucial now than ever
nestled in the bucolic hills of new
england sits the mayflower in the newest
outpost of the well
a new york city-based center focused on
wellness and relaxation
rebecca park is the co-founder and ceo
we know how healing nature can be and so
to create an opportunity for guests to
really go deep on their journey
through overnight retreats and
experiences some of the signature
treatments we've created
are intentionally designed to take place
in nature treatments like this
an outdoor massage under a canopy of
trees
we created a treatment where the massage
table is warmed with infrared heat
and so you're laying on the table
getting this profound craniosacral
treatment
while looking up at the trees so
creating these kind of magical moments
and experiences for people
other services at the well range from 50
to 600
offerings vary from yoga and meditation
classes
to acupuncture to one-on-one sessions
with a health coach
park was first inspired to create what
she calls an ecosystem for wellness
after working on a trading desk during
the 2008 financial crisis
i found that it was very challenging to
make time
for wellness and really just to
prioritize it and then
even when i did attempt to say i need to
find a yoga studio or i need to figure
out how to sleep more
it was just very disparate there were so
many amazing wellness
experiences and brands that were coming
to life in new york that everything was
fragmented
the well aims to change that by offering
all
wellness related services under one roof
centers like these represent the newest
frontier in the booming 4.5
trillion dollar global wellness economy
craig reed is president and ceo of
auberge resorts
parent company to the mayflower inn he
says the hospitality industry is
evolving
factoring wellness into the business
people
are constantly concerned about their
physical health their emotional health
we in our resorts we sort of see them as
havens
as retreats where people can go and
escape and
renew and be re-energized and so
wellness for us
in a place like this is about uh sort of
supporting that journey of renewal
and encouragement but rebecca park
acknowledges
wellness can feel out of reach for many
you're talking about
meditation and yoga and things that may
not be part of their own
routines or lies what would you say to
people who
look at this and say well that's
wellness for the well-off
i think it's a fair point and i think
it's a valid question and i think it's
something that we need to talk about
more
so i think first off i think as a
wellness company
thought leaders in the wellness industry
have a responsibility to advocate for
policy and systemic change
that makes wellness accessible to more
people psychiatrist dr marquita wills
says wellness is critical for everyone
i'd argue that it's it's not a luxury
in fact in times like these during high
stress times
it's actually a necessity because the
thing of the matter is
if we don't take care of ourselves it
comes out it comes out in other ways
it'll come out with weight gain it'll
come out with inability to sleep it'll
come out with being
argumentative and irritable at work so
we got to take charge of it so that we
can be our best selves and live our best
lives
and dr wills says self-care doesn't have
to cost a lot
you can buy epsom salt throw it in your
tub
and create your own spa with a candle at
home and so building those restorative
experiences into
our lives are so important especially
now
as for the well the pandemic forced its
new york city location to temporarily
shut its doors
but provided an opportunity to introduce
the company's services to a wider
audience
we very quickly pivoted and brought all
of our services online
we created a telehealth platform we
started live streaming our fitness
classes
we started offering free meditation led
by one of our teachers
now park hopes more people will see why
wellness matters
our mental and emotional well-being is
certainly being challenged right now you
know we were experiencing a mental
health crisis in america
prior to copin 19. the amount of stress
and anxiety that people are experiencing
on a day-to-day basis
is really challenging and daunting so i
think it's critical that we come
together
as individuals as businesses as a
collective society and help each other
heal right now
all right so we should mention that we
shot some of this before the pandemic
before
social distancing hence some of the
footage that you saw there but
dr wills says it's really important for
people to understand this is for
everyone people of all backgrounds and
that sleep
dr will said should be a priority we all
know how
sleep can affect us but really there's
just a myriad of body processes that are
affected when you don't get enough sleep
um she says also just meditate if you
can which sounds like a tall order for a
lot of people
they don't like to do that but just even
10 minutes take a breath yes
but i love the epsom salt and a candle
that's right
when all else fails that's right